[Music]
foreign
so here in this kind of slideshow video
we will showcase all the images of
Godzilla XCOM the hunted the new Comics
that will be released all the images
that are out there in the internet
swimming the vast digital ocean so we
also have kind of arranged them in what
we think will be in a proper sequence
but we could be wrong we don't know
anyway let's get to it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
uh
foreign
[Music]
and yeah I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam